Wesley versus Mishra again Wesley kind
of complaining that uh he's playing this
Berlin defense making easy draws with
the black pieces but not getting any
wins he's going to have to sharpen up
his openings well guess what uh in this
line of the fiser variation of the
nidorf he got a very double-edged
position H2 H4 and Mishra said well
that's an invitation for me to make the
class iCal sicil open Sicilian exchange
sacrifice Rook takes E3 we have seen
this in thousands of games is this one
of those positions Kate before I go any
further where you uh would make the
exchange sacrifice yourself as black yes
I like the sacrifices on C3 I think it
allows black a very easy play right
because you do have two Targets you have
C3 targets you have A3 a Target and you
just want to improve your knight you
want to put something on the C file